recently breitbart released a report
showing that much of the non-profits
that were going after elon musk
criticizing his attempted buying twitter
were funded by bill gates
elon musk was already very critical of
bill gates even posting a meme of him as
the pregnant man emoji and we all had a
laugh but now he's responded to the
story saying sai
now i don't know exactly what that means
other than elon knows about it but this
resulted in breitbart trending earlier
today on twitter because
elon responding to it has elevated this
story and there's something interesting
here because
there's like some kind of yin yang good
versus evil elon versus gates thing
going on where elon musk is like hey we
need more people like you you you need
more people on this planet to sustain
and develop and grow and population is
declining these are bad things and free
speech the people should have a right
should have freedom and then bill gates
is exactly the opposite saying we need
to reduce population and free speech is
bad issuing a statement saying he's
gonna he's gonna muck things up on
twitter so this is actually a really
interesting story that gets to the heart
of this this i mean you've got two
billionaires basically at war
in the greater culture war so we'll talk
about that we've got a couple other
stories democrats have won
a an appeal to a federal court allowing
them to now pursue disqualifying
republicans from being able to run for
office under the 14th amendment
so there was a ruling saying you can't
use the 14th amendment
to disqualify republicans because of
this clemency bill that happened in 1872
and a federal court said no that's not
true if if you today after the civil war
insurrect you can be barred from running
for office
so it doesn't mean anybody's been found
to be
insurrecting against the united states
but you've already got many democrats
saying anyone who voted to uh not to
certify the election in 2020 committed
insurrection so this is where they're
going they can't win the election so
they're going for law fair which says to
me that all of this is just pushing us
ever closer from civil strife into some
kind of civil war and don't don't take
my word for it robert reich wrote an
article where he explained that you know
it's not going to be a civil war it's
going to be a peaceful divorce that
people will just slowly start going to
other places the red you know red voters
will go to red states and blue voters to
blue states and it's funny because uh
that's kind of exactly what was
happening with the first civil war so
we'll talk about all that stuff we'll
talk about tech oligarchy and censorship
and joining us to talk about this today
actually we have two ian's um but uh our
first guest aaron wolfe hi there i'm
aaron wolfe i'm uh working on tech
freedom
do you want to get a little bit about
your background maybe you could you want
to point the microphone just like trying
to aim it
at your mouth there we go there you go
perfect for you what do you do um so i'm
a programmer i dropped out of grad
school in uh
97 to go work at yahoo um
basically spent 18 years in silicon
valley
um
going
with the flow for the most part but also
kind of being an obnoxious dissenter a
lot of the times too
um
by 20 uh
i basically worked for five years at
yahoo
did random gigs of nonsense
invested in whatsapp
doubled my money several times
investing in big tech and
kind of
at a certain point i decided i needed to
like
do what i dropped out of grad school for
which is uh
you know create good software so i'm
trying to do what i can to kind of
facilitate
good software um
to be created and i don't see any of the
big tech giants doing that now they're
actually
conspiring to make our software worse in
many different ways and the censorship
kind of is
the biggest right now and you're
involved with minds.com yes one of the
first things i did is invest in
minds.com so i help them you know keep
going they're doing great work uh you
know with an open source social network
um
very very focused on freedom of speech
right on right and we also have another
ian
hey i'm ian mason uh i'm helping aaron
build fudo i moved to austin to do that
yeah i mean his his mission just
attracted me uh this um
the internet and the tech world as we
had it for 20 25 years there created so
much it created it democratized speech
it uh it allowed access to i gave people
access to information like they'd never
had before i mean this show couldn't
possibly be happening happening without
that sort of uh the freewheeling spirit
of the tech world prior to
maybe 10 years ago
and if we're going to preserve that i
think it can't just be done through
politics it has to be done through
technological means and and that's what
i feel like aaron's mission is and i'm
here to help him so as we talk about big
tech censorship and the tech oligarchs
and all that stuff you mentioned futo
right what so this is what you guys are
working on what is it just so people get
a general idea of like what your mission
is and what's the background
um so futo's an organization we're
basically spending a lot of money trying
to
do whatever we can to chip away at the
power that the tech oligopoly has
so
we're going to be funding people with
grant programs
get them coding get people coding get
people to quit their jobs at google and
facebook there's a lot of people at
those companies who hate those companies
but they're getting they don't know what
if there's anything else they can do
that's interesting even yeah so uh you
know project veritas is often telling
people be brave you know let us know if
these things are going on but a lot of
people feel like if they do they're
they're gonna be destitute they're not
gonna have anywhere to go they're not
gonna be able to work anywhere so i
think people need to understand there's
there's other places to be where you can
work or there's at least you guys are
encouraging them to get away from that
and build something new and unique so we
will talk about that it's gonna be
interesting we also have original ian
what up everybody yeah it's great that
we're talking about bill gates because a
lot about this you know we talk about
the the locking down of the tech
industry in the early 80s he's kind of
notorious for taking i think it was unix
code and correct me if i'm wrong maybe
you guys could tell the story better
than i could um he bought ms-dos
from another company and basically
worked with ibm to kind of dominate
um with intel it was called wintel in
those days and he took he took free
software and then made it private or
took open source code and then
privatized it i don't know if it was
open source but it was
you know i don't i don't think it was
open source i think was proprietary he
bought it and then you know distributed
i remember richard stallman you know
just all about the open source community
free software he's the guy that wrote
agpl3 and stuff i mean the worst thing
that bill gates did is he um
actively conspired to keep linux from
ever getting a a huge a decent market
share we should save this
i'm also here pushing buttons in the
corner i'm sure i will be overwhelmed by
all the tech terms in this show so
please pray for my button pushing skills
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become members help support
our work directly as a member you will
keep our journalists working you will
get access to exclusive segments from
this show monday through thursday at 11
pm and you're also supporting exactly
this alternative infrastructure we are
using rumble's cloud infrastructure to
try and get away from big tech silicon
valley at the very least create
competition and let them know every
single time i bring it up on every
episode it's on purpose so they know
that people are building alternatives
that we can use them that they're
working and we are finding success on
these platforms and so can you and that
means if they don't shape up and change
what they're doing
we're gonna leave and we can leave and
that's that's one of the most powerful
things you can do as a member to support
more businesses that are using
technology outside of silicon valley so
don't forget to also smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and let's
jump into that first story from the
daily mail
billionaires at war elon musk deepens
feud with bill gates
by touting article claiming the
microsoft mogul poured millions into
dark money fund targeting him that is
dastardly but before we show anything i
want to show you this
elon musk posting the pregnant man emoji
next to a photo of bill gates
so here's the funny thing he posted this
april 22nd and it shows you know bill
gates it's the haircut's the same
you know there's not wearing glasses but
he's got a big belly and a blue shirt
and uh you just need to understand that
elon posted this
uh bill gates had already been funding
these groups now here's the crazy thing
apparently bill gates reached out to
elon musk about donating or some kind of
philanthropy but was was running a 500 i
think it was 500 million right 500
million short against tesla and elon's
like i'm doing the most for climate
change and you're trying to short my
position i don't trust you so they've
kind of been going at it the one thing i
want to reiterate for this as we start
this segment is that elon is a guy who
said
we need more people you know if you you
need more people to sustain this the
civilization and this planet to colonize
other planets and all of that stuff and
people should have free speech should
have you know the right to use his
platforms and speak and all that stuff
bill gates is the opposite we need less
people there's too many and people
shouldn't have that free speech it's
really interesting we have these two
billionaire factions going at each other
so uh in this story
the report came out that bill gates
poured millions of dollars into dark
money fund attacking elon musk he
responded with psy
that's it but it does
it does say a lot as soon as elon
acknowledged breitbart what ends up
happening is breitbart began begins
trending on twitter
every every blue check journalist starts
claiming oh breitbart is fake news you
don't trust it and now they're trying to
claim you know once again like oh elon
musk he's far right or whatever i think
this just goes to show that there are
efforts to silence us from very powerful
interests
whether
you whether you like breitbart or not
bill gates absolutely is funding ngos
many of these many of these big
corporations we see we just saw state
farm i think it was state farm they had
this thing where they were sending you
know lgbtq stuff for kids all of this
stuff is happening behind the scenes all
of these groups are you know opposed to
free speech
so what happens next
uh what do you guys think i think that
we double down on the u.s constitution
but i'd like to hear yeah i mean to me
bill gates embodies kind of the tech
elitism that i fled when i left silicon
valley um
it very much is this very pompous
attitude that you know
if people are allowed like if we allow
these people to think for themselves
like they're gonna give us bad results
like and it is just like they're so
stupid we have to take care of them like
it's very much like there are there are
pets almost like i feel i don't feel
like bill gates is evil
but he doesn't trust the everyday
person to kind of make their own
decisions read information read alex
jones or watch alex jones right watch
all these things and come to their own
conclusions
whereas elon musk does seem to be
you know to some degree you know
fighting kind of for the
the more common man fighting for a free
speech
you know yes every like he's not saying
like only elite should have children
he's saying we should all have more
children things like that well he
actually had a tweet earlier he said i
think this is today right yeah he said
most rich people he knows most people
you know says like have like one or two
kids yes or no it's like one or none
right yeah and then he's got eight yeah
true he has eight kids yeah there's a
lot of kids go dad yeah
yeah i mean i mean that's that is
rampant in silicon valley this this
belief and i think it was big in the 70s
too of just like
there's too many kids like
a lot of them think that there should be
licenses to have kids
they don't even have kids
yeah they don't have kids themselves
you're right i mean i gotta say haven't
you uh ever encountered someone that was
just so stupid you were like you know
what bill gates is right
yeah absolutely but but it's it's you
know
they're
you got to you got to believe in free i
mean for me i believe in freedom first
so yeah like
maybe you see that person and think that
but then who's going to work at the
licensing office right maybe that guy so
yeah right
take that exactly when i think about how
they founded the u.s the us government
it was kind of like an elitist they had
an elite like they were like we can't
trust the common man to govern
themselves so we're going to create a
congress to do it for them just in case
no that that is the common man well it's
a representative of the common man yeah
i think the most intelligent among them
to i mean what were they going to do
they weren't going to do a direct
democracy because that doesn't work mobs
are dangerous but but the you know
before the united states it was a king
who ruled by decree and it was just like
do as you're told pay your taxes and
they were like we just want
representation they're like no i think
with social media when you get like what
they call fake news or like
misinformation disinformation it's the
mob mentality that's dangerous if a
piece of bad information goes out and
then everyone shares it or if 50 million
people share it it's kind of like
democracy in action and i get i see the
danger in it yeah no bad things can
happen i mean there was a problem where
some indian
village or we've been told there was an
indian village that started like
murdering tourists because there was
some like superstition about
torah that spread on whatsapp like but
at the end of the day
you know
yeah it's a it's a double-edged sword
i'm gonna go for i'm gonna be on the
side of freedom they they have this uh
utopian view of everything saying like
there's a problem happening we can solve
it you can't solve it you you can't and
we're witnessing this with
all of the big tech stuff they they try
banning memes and then what happens they
end up banning the you know random
people on accident and banning a bunch
of regular people the famous moment was
when the editor-in-chief of the daily
caller got banned for referencing
learn to code because they created an
automated system saying okay anybody
saying learn to code you gotta ban them
why
they're a bunch of white like you know
what it really feels like they're a
bunch of they're like the class
president you know they're snooty and
elitist and they're angry that
everyone's laughing and having fun
they're like stop having fun is not
allowed and so they just like tell the
algorithm to ban anybody says learn to
code that's a really bad idea here's a
really great example remember when the
ceo of reddit went to the donald and
manually changed the comments from
donald users because he was mad at them
talk about a whiny pathetic
loser
someone said mean words so he went into
the reddit database and changed what
they said
yeah that guy's just so sad what a loser
and he's got how much money see this is
the problem this is why i agree we can't
we can't be like we need licensing and
we need to restrict free speech because
then you get losers like that in charge
of the system which you have now and
they flex their muscles thinking i
should be in charge and then the dupety
garbage like that
how sad
my biggest takeaway from the from the
breitbart piece as well is that so many
of those arguments are made in bad faith
which i think is what you're getting at
you know the same people who are now
saying we don't want this this uh this
purchase you know they have ties to bill
gates or they have ties to other
industry people um the same people who
before this saga were saying you know
actually there is no censorship
everything is just is just moderation
and all that when elon says he's maybe
going to buy this
suddenly there is censorship and not
only is it real it's actually essential
that it continue for our democracy to
continue to function and in all cases
these arguments are you know there were
bad faith arguments before and they're
being revised i understand local
censorship like uh in your house it's
your rules and if the kids speak up out
of turn you know it's your house they
follow your law that's your you're
censoring your but top-down censorship
doesn't work doesn't seem to work not i
mean not really not really you well you
have like sedition laws and stuff
parents and kids and small you know
private homes is one thing it's like
it's my house if somebody comes over and
they they act up i'm gonna be like bro
you can leave it's my house now that's
the argument we we see from a lot of
democrats like it's a private company
and i'm just like yeah who controls the
common space where adults are all trying
to discuss with each other there is no
super parent there's no like
you know after you're 100 years old 100
years old you elevate to a higher
authority of adult no no we're all
adults we all have thoughts and opinions
we all have rights and we're going to
argue those things
they think they shouldn't have to argue
at all they think they should just be
able to stamp you out and a good example
is what's happening with this lawsuit
democrats are trying to disqualify
republicans instead of saying i'm going
to stand in front of the common people
and tell them my thoughts and my plans
i'm going to go to the judge and say he
shouldn't be allowed to run for office
come on judge ban him because they can't
win they don't want to actually play by
the rules they're whiny pathetic losers
what have you guys found is the most
resilient
i guess resistance towards this stuff at
this point
in what fashion well like uh the best
tech you could build to to circumvent
censorship or over like censorship
that's gone too far
well i i kind of was talking about like
one of the biggest hurdles that we have
to overcome i mean i would say like it's
gotten way worse with the app stores
with with
iphone totally locking down their
computer it used to be that you could
program whatever you wanted and
your friends could install it and now
apple approves what you can do um and
they'll even like like take you off of
the store if your buttons and you know
if steve jobs is corpse doesn't like
where your button is
um you'll you can get removed from the
store
um for real they'll remove stuff for
design yes yes really
what's an example of that well
um
they have very strict guidelines for for
their designs so
um
so my company that i helped start in
2014 we got removed because it was
um it wasn't quite for design it was
because and it wasn't really removed it
was just we couldn't upgrade it and it
was because
um
they weren't happy that we were allowing
people we were we kind of looked like we
had a list of games they were like oh
you have a list of games in your app
that's that's kind of our job we have
the list of games on ours thing so like
we we might be competing too much with
apple
um and then they they said we couldn't
upgrade until we made it feel
like it was less of a
um
list of games and more like a chat app
they said it's okay if you have a chat
app it's not okay if you have a list of
games yeah roblox is on the apple app
store and it is the that's exact thing
it's a list of games they call them
experiences right so they've they've
they it's
you probably deal this with youtube all
the time they like their guidelines are
always shifting right so they kind of
have this gray area where they can
operate in and they can
enforce things
in a irregular fashion
and they
absolutely
have like people at facebook
who you know they facebook gets to do
what they want way more than like a
smaller developer gets to do what they
want
and like if you're an open source
developer trying to create like you know
something federated like matrix or
something it's even harder when you're
looking at f droid whenever i think
about like open source app stores i
think of f droid is that good or is it
dangerous or what's the deal i mean they
would say it's dangerous i think it's
great like i want more people using you
know the the open source the um
they're they're called the uh they're
basically operating systems based on the
android open source project
which you know
people have
removed the google control from so yeah
you can install graphene os or lineage
os and install f droid and kind of get
whatever apps you want but this is you
know for the average person they have no
idea what you just said to be honest you
know what's f droid what is what yeah
and that's kind of i agree that's that's
one of the things that we really want to
focus on with futo too is educating
people about their options and also
making them better i mean we have to
admit that
the oligopoly is doing a great job at
building these things like
very easy the product is really good
that's the the first problem with with
the tech oligopoly is
yes
the app store i think is one thing
that's often overlooked in the
discussion about free speech because
that's probably the most important
because even if you like
we all saw gab get pulled from the app
store and banned and then they have to
find alternative means means to get in
getting back on the app store one of the
funniest things i think they did was
they created a clone of the uh the
fetiverse app
which is it's just a
it's there's no website it's just a
shell
then you plug in where you want to go
and oh it can boot up you know gabs you
know servers
that got banned too and they were like
it's a clone i think it was a clone of
mastodon or something and so i was like
why was that it wasn't a clone of
medicine i think it was a clone of
fetiverse
so for those that aren't familiar with
what this means it's like a web browser
it's like they ban your website so you
launch your own web browser and then
they ban your web browser and it's just
that
that's how insane the control of these
two app stores really is
maybe maybe there's something there i
mean you know bill gates got hit for
antitrust for what putting internet
explorer on all these uh windows
machines is that what happened
yeah that was in the late 90s when um
netscape was uh dominating the browser
market and
um you know
if you want to talk about bill gates
like the first thing he did before that
even happened before the internet even
got big is i believe it was dell
was trying to sell pcs with linux
pre-installed instead of windows wow so
linux would have would have had like a
decent market share and gotten a lot
more momentum than it got as a desktop
operating system what bill gates did is
he basically um
he did some sort of deal i don't know
the details precisely but it was
something about like
unless you're exclusive microsoft
windows on your pcs that you're shipping
you're going to pay a lot more per
license so dell would pay like you know
five bucks a license or something for
windows and it would have been 10 bucks
or something if they had als if they
kept selling linux machines so so
linux is awesome
i uh uh for those that aren't familiar
it's it's open source free operating
system that works really really well i i
guess because it's uh linux it most
people would recognize it because it's
similar to mac os right
um
yeah mac os was derived from a unix um
it was derived more from freebsd which
is unix hard to tell the difference
really but so you know for for all of
you out there who use mac you might
easily understand what uh what linux is
i think a lot of uh big chain stores use
linux for their terminals for like self
checkout and stuff because it's free and
they have to pay licenses but it's
really amazing i didn't know that story
that bill gates basically shut that down
because
imagine if we did not have
microsoft windows as the dominant
platform imagine if it was a free open
source technology
and you get some
jerk
like bill gates who comes in and sticks
his foot you know in the door and then
stops that from happening so he can
control that piece and now you have tech
oligarchs like him specifically and now
he's gone from just being some guy who's
like i think you should have my
operating system instead too there's too
many people on this planet and we should
have less people right and all that went
i know tim you bring up antitrust
enforcement because that has played sort
of a a role as a final check here over
the decades it took 10 years of
practices like that before finally it
was the the internet uh explorer
integration that finally did trigger
that
we've seen far less you know antitrust
has not provided uh an effective check
uh in the last bit here on what i think
most observers would say is at least
somewhat anti-competitive practices
among app stores and a hundred other
things we could go into
i think that the fact is we need
something like fudo because um antitrust
is not going to to handle it on its own
there are there are things that inherent
in the system as it exists now that are
anti-competitive that make it i mean
down to the engineers themselves that
this sort of um
the model of silicon valley now is to
lock up talented engineers within four
or five or six companies forever but not
based particularly on their output but
based on the fact that them being there
prevents viable alternatives from coming
into existence
now steve jobs i hear he was kind of a
dick as well was that the case
i mean
sure yeah i mean i i would say like one
quality that like you know all these
oligarchs um
the the trait that they have in commons
they're they're all kind of me
steve jobs is maybe special but it's
like if you look like someone like mark
zuckerberg they're mediocre
above average programmers right maybe
they're you know top 10 programmers what
the trait they really have is they do
like to control things
so like bill gates
was having a connection when linux when
dell was trying to sell linux computers
mark zuckerberg was having a conniption
when he saw that you know tons of people
were uploading photos to whatsapp
instead of facebook like which you know
within a couple years that happened
so yeah so steve jobs is the same thing
like very very very very controlling
people
like steve jobs is like
you must have one i don't know if you
remember he insisted on one mouse button
for a long time even though there were
so many people who wanted like two mouse
buttons well there was the gag i think
it was the onion who made it where the
new mac was just instead of a keyboard
it was a it was a wheel
and if you wanted to try it you had to
wheel to the letter and then press the
button because it's just simpler that
way right i i couldn't i could i
couldn't stand apple it's the same thing
it's like these these these people want
to
control and extract as much as they can
from from everybody now look good
business good for them i suppose but i
remember my friends
telling me that they were they were
obligated by their professors to buy mac
to use it for school or whatever and i'm
like that's five times more expensive
for the same processing power they take
it was it freebsd you said you take a
unix system they slap their logo on and
then charge you money for it
i mean they did i'll give them a bit of
a pass they did a lot of good work and
honestly you know in 2006 2007
they were still very small market share
like they actually did beat microsoft by
making it better so i'll give steve jobs
a pass you know if if you're the small
guy and you're you know trying to
control things
that's okay
if you're like if you have your vision
your unified vision for a beautiful
product and you're at 10 market share go
at it as soon as you get to you know
have too much power like 50 market share
and the only other player is also 50
you know that's when you gotta like step
you know step it back a bit for sure i
suppose it's fair to say steve jobs
never came out and said there's too many
people so we got to figure out how to
reduce those numbers
and population growth because that's
kind of a weird thing for a for a
computer guy to say oh buying farms and
stuff yeah yeah
it kind of makes me think like
it when you have a big
uh network you kind of want to see what
the people want and then build the
network to support that as opposed to
build a network that decides what the
people are going to want but that
there's so many people that want so many
different things it becomes challenging
if not impossible to to support all
those different ideas at once that might
be what's stopping them from why they
become so authoritarian and controlling
the network
but i haven't been in that position yet
so i'm not sure exactly what's causing
it
to to rise to the position where you are
running a company like microsoft you
have to genuinely believe you're smarter
and better than everybody so it's like
if you if you take a hundred people and
you you put them in a sieve and you
shake it as hard as you can to see what
falls out and what sticks
the people who hold on the tightest you
know they're the ones who are have that
have that energy so naturally the person
who rises to the top at big massive
companies like this are the people who
are like i'm smarter i'm better
everyone's got to do what i say
that's why you end up with a bill gates
yeah and the collusion works i mean the
closing works you're going to win if
you're colluding
somebody who just wants to you know
likes competition and wants if they see
a threat and they say well let's do
better like let's view this as a
friendly competition that person's going
to lose to the colluders so it's you
know it's
kind of formed naturally this monopoly
in in a lot of ways and i want to add
one more thing to what i was just saying
uh there i was reading about how
celebrities tend to be sociopaths they
tend to be narcissists and egotistical
er very arrogant
and it's actually fairly simple as to
why that is
you have two people
one person is very humble one person is
narcissistic which one's going to get up
on stage and shout out how beautiful and
amazing they are it's going to be the
narcissist the humble person's gonna be
like well you know maybe it's not for me
you're gonna have someone say i'd like
to audition for this role and they're
gonna say we don't know if you haven't
they're gonna go well okay you know i'll
try harder next time you get the
arrogant narcissistic guy and he's gonna
be like no no you're wrong i am the best
and i'm gonna prove it to you and
they're like this guy's got energy those
people are going to rise to the top and
that's one of the challenges we face i
suppose with a free market is that snake
oil salesmen
con artists arrogant narcissists are the
ones who end up gaining tons and tons of
power and rarely do you find someone who
doesn't have those qualities but just
does a really good job or i should say
not rarely but less often
i mean
yeah they they get bored or they they
feel like they've accomplished something
and they just want to live their life
they don't really care about controlling
things and and they've done their thing
there are a lot of people
many people i follow on twitter for
instance and yeah they they do really
well and they're like well you know i
did my thing and i don't want to be the
boss i want to be in charge and they dip
out it's like the killer instinct
probably is what they call it it comes
from our past hunting like if you were
if you didn't have that killer instinct
and you couldn't hunt properly then you
would die and you didn't but the ones
that could hunt and kill and then kill
the their opponents so that their
village didn't get raided and murdered
then they survived so now there's this
killer instinct in business which is
like maybe we're doing it wrong
that's why i'm doing free software
anyway i think it's i think i think it's
wrong i don't understand locking down
all the money it doesn't make sense i
always go back to culture is is the most
important if if we if if as a culture
people were into open source and linux
and stuff bill gates would lose all his
power and he'd be like the wicked witch
of the west melting like
people adopting linux across the board
would be incredible for that reason we
got to explain it you said graphene os
so you get an android phone you you
flash graphene os onto it which
basically means you erase the operating
system and reinstall a new one um which
is an open source software called
graphing os right right it's uh this guy
daniel mckay is doing graphene os and
there's a few other
groups doing similar things with the
android open source project um
so
one these things we have to understand
we need to make these things better
before we're going to get tens of
millions of people using them which is
what i you know i want there to be i
wanted to be hundreds of millions of
people using
software that is not locked down by the
oligopoly how do you do it how do you
flash a new software operating system on
your phone
um it's i just did it it was uh not easy
i i bought the phone they told me to buy
it turned out that it was locked down at
some point in the history of the uh
phone
because it was refurbished so i had to
get another phone
um
you know you go through you can go
through the the instructions at the
graphene os site it's pretty pretty
pretty straightforward like
your grandmother could probably do it or
your mother-in-law could probably do it
if she has the right phone like
and it's still gonna not work as well as
you want though it's worth it i love it
i i most of the phones i've had
throughout my life except for except for
iphone i can't stand iphone
would i would always put on some either
bare bones android operating system just
gut all of the bloat and the garbage
that they put into it and then just get
that base system or using something you
know like graphene there's been a whole
bunch throughout the history of android
that are just better simpler cleaner
safer et cetera what are some problems
with it you were saying that sometimes
it doesn't work as good what's the
problem with it yeah i mean that's
that's the problem i mean you have uh
problems with like uber working with
your
phones tim was that like does uber work
well with your phone like a lot of these
okay yeah so some of these some of these
apps that people expect to work won't
work especially notif anything very
notification heavy you know those rely
on google's uh services to work that
well right so is that a monopoly
google's notification system
uh it's not quite a monopoly but it's
one of these things that as we like to
say that this google software is much
more delightful both for the user and
the developer um so there's a long way
to come in that a big that's not a slide
against graphene or any of these other
groups they're doing fantastic work i
i've been using windows since 93 or 92
windows 3.1 and uh it's because of video
games i use steam and i couldn't game on
linux for like late 90s early 2000s i
mean valve is doing a lot of great work
trying to make linux work well for games
and i i think that like i'm a gamer like
like i've i started out doing games for
yahoo
so i love what valve's doing to try to
make linux better for games but it just
does kind of hammer home how difficult
this problem is that
valve is this super
super powerful i consider them to be
like one of the better
companies that's kind of on the more
independent side of things with steam
being so popular
they have not been able to
deliver a successful linux product yet
they're trying now the steam deck
um hopefully that works i want to jump
to some current events from today and
talk about the ramifications of this
control and these oligarchs and where
we're currently at because it's a hard
segue into more political stuff but i
think all of this is tied together in
the culture war from timcast.com court
rules anyone charged as an
insurrectionist can be barred from
political office the decision comes
after north carolina voters challenged
madison cawthorne's re-election bid to
put it simply
we thought that this was crushed because
democrats are basically trying to make
it so that people like marjorie taylor
greene madison cawthorne cannot run for
re-election
what ends up happening is the court says
because of this clemency act or whatever
in 1872 you can't use this against
people anymore now a federal court says
federal court says now actually you can
so one of the things we end up seeing
from all of this manipulation and
control on social media they're trying
to craft the narrative they've been
trying as hard as possible before free
you know an open internet
before we all were
our culture developed on on the internet
the big uh networks controlled
everything if they said it it was true
and that's power
the media has been desperately trying to
claim that all of these republicans are
insurrectionists simply because they
voted not to certify election results
because they wanted an investigation or
who knows why they did it you also had i
think half the states in a lawsuit
against the other half of the states at
one point with texas leading the charge
taking issue with how the election was
handled in 2020
now they're trying to argue that that
everything that uh happened was an
insurrection and therefore 147
republicans can be barred from office i
i gotta say just the fact that there is
a vote to
to verify the election results means
that you can vote yes or no they have a
vote on purpose so it doesn't matter how
you vote on that well this is this is
the crazy thing that i think we see with
everything
why is it that
they they don't want free speech because
they don't want a fair playing field
they don't want to have to deal with
proving themselves right why are they
going after the this this 14th amendment
thing because they're going to lose they
know they're going to lose
we are we are dealing with an
establishment it's it's it's the big
tech companies the media companies the
democratic party many republicans as
well they're part of the establishment
and their goal is just to maintain
control and power by any means necessary
is this true that so it's just being
charged with this it's not even being
convicted it's just being charged can
bar someone even if they're found
innocent well being charged for
insurrection is is nebulous
it's what does it mean
i don't know the media the media said
the media has repeatedly said
definitively that certain people
have committed insurrection they're just
they're just outright saying it and
that's why they tried arguing
they they they tried suing saying no
medicine catherine can't run because by
speaking this event he engaged in
insurrection man i'm using brave and i'm
using the brave search brave browser
research i just typed in insurrection to
get a definition the on the right 2021
united states capital attack attack
comes up it says attack like this is
mass media manipulation in my face and
it's brave what do we what
insurrection and they just assume that
i'm and well i mean
i suppose you can say some people a lot
of people there did attack you know i
guess then we ask propaganda right you
say attack on one side and you say
protest on the other side
yup and whoever controls the narrative
is going to control the outcome
and taken to its logical conclusion yeah
you wind up with one of the constitution
the sovereign constitutional branches of
government democratic branches of
government uh having its sovereignty uh
replaced with with that of of another
whatever you want to call this other
media branch or whoever whoever's going
to decide um what is an insurrection in
the public eye
they are able to decide when
um what we would take as the the
unlimited sovereignty of congress to
vote how it will be to impose its will
on the other two branches that's laid
out in the constitution comes to an end
and i mean
that's scary this is why our ability to
speak freely in the public is so
important for the longest time
you spoke in the public or i mean
actually alongside people go to churches
and they would talk to each other you
also had physical events but you did
have media controlling a large share of
what people thought was true and they
just blindly believed it
now with the internet
they're trying to lock down i think they
were surprised by 2016 they didn't
realize how powerful the internet was
going to be that
people basically memed trump into the
presidency they have to stop it so they
go after alex jones they go after you
know milo they go after laura loomer all
of these people who are on the right who
are allowed and generating tons of
attention
all of a sudden we see one day
alex jones gets purged from basically
every single from from app stores from
podcasts from every social platform
there's no way that wasn't coordinated
you can see the coordination too when
one network will ban it and then within
like a week another network bans it you
could just be say that like maybe
facebook watched twitter ban them and
was like we're gonna follow suit but i
got a feeling i mean you were in silicon
valley you'd know better than anyone i
actually think it was more than just
kind of like this group thing and like
with alex jones alex jones is probably
the best example of this where like
within a day like he was removed from
three or four platforms yeah i feel like
there was just so much so many people
whining to get rid of alex jones at
those companies as soon as one of them
actually like like dove into the pool
they all just kind of followed
automatically afterwards
so i don't i i guess maybe i'm a bit of
a skeptic on like that they had like a
boardroom meeting where they all decided
now is when we
ban alex jones it's just one group like
if they had like a meeting in like davos
switzerland or something to decide all
that stuff that'd be crazy i think it's
the middle ground i don't think that
they all had you know they pressed the
button to go to the sub basement where
all of the big tech buildings meet and
they sit in the council chamber with
torches or anything like that i think
they went out to lunch and they were
like
what are you what are you guys doing
over at twitter about this alex jones
thing and they're like well we don't
exactly what are you guys over at
facebook doing what we're thinking about
banning them and then you know a handful
of guys who were from different
departments were talking they went back
and said that's what they're going to do
and so then when one person did okay and
then everyone does it because they walk
in lockstep with each other yeah they're
probably probably like one of them one
of them texts their friend over in the
same department at a other company and
says we finally got rid of alex jones
yeah and then they text their friends at
the you know new york times the
washington post as well they said this
is what we're going to do and then those
people get in touch with the pr
department of the tech company that
hasn't done taken the same action says
did you know you know we that these
other platforms are going to ban them
what are you doing are you going to
allow this to continue on yours
exclusively yup and the nail that sticks
out gets hammered and they know that i
uh
if there is one one profession that i i
would say i despise more than anything
it's probably journalists
because like the actual real profession
is is honorable noble and important
that's not what we have today in any
sense of the imagination i mean you got
a handful you've got you know maybe a
handful of people over at breitbart alan
bakari for instance a friend of ours
who's done great reporting on the tech
censorship stuff you've got good
journalists who really do work at a lot
of mainstream corporate press that's a
fact like local outlets especially they
do they do their job a lot of reporting
is like you know the local fire
department is being shut down for
renovations and they're telling their
local community oh that's fantastic but
we have at the highest level
exactly what you just described where a
journalist
will reach out and say hi i'm calling
from the new york times and i'm just
wondering why you support white
supremacy by allowing alex jones on your
platform we're going to write that you
are klansmen by the way and then the
company freaks out and they're like no
no no no we'll ban them we'll ban him
please leave us alone please don't wield
the power of your you know millions of
views or whatever against us i wonder if
it's more uh more coordinated because
i'm looking at who owns meta which is
facebook's parent company well vanguard
blackrock state street those are the
three of the top four there's also
fidelity management who owns alphabet
the parent company of google vanguard
blackrock state street yeah uh so is it
the the corporate ceos of these are
there even ceos because these companies
own each other when you start to look
into it you're like who runs what like
is it just 20 dudes sitting in their
mountain base like okay now we're making
like do they decide facebook's gonna ban
alex jones or was that mark who makes
that decision these guys own twenty
percent of the company these these three
these three corporations own almost
twenty percent of these companies both
of them
i it's just a question that maybe can't
be answered because that's they've
obuscated it on purpose
yeah i don't know the answer to that um
it's potential there's a lot more
collusion coming from the top up uh
you know i would say this that you know
the ceos of these companies do have to
be good to be successful so they they
have a fair amount of independence
good
that's an interesting word good well
well
effective they have to be good managers
they have to be able to juggle a lot of
balls um
i mean if you look at what bill gates is
funding
there's coordination not not in the
sense maybe where these companies like i
said you know go to the sub basement
have a cabal meet or anything like that
but
it's not as complicated as people might
think it is when they say oh you're
believing conspiracies oh that's
nonsense no no look a rich dude hires
people who do does the things that he
likes
so uh i mean look fudo wants to hire
programmers to you know get him out of
silicon valley bill gates wants to hire
people and give access to resources who
don't believe in free speech and want to
reduce the population
so reduce population growth to be more
specific so he is going to hire people
who are powerfully advocating for these
things and empower what he wants and
he's got the resources to do it
so then he gives money to a bunch of
different groups all of those groups
agree all of those groups join forces
and now you've got this coordinated
massive wave of companies many of them
focusing in different areas but now
they're coalescing around one thing elon
musk bad
there's a coordination
be it on accident or otherwise
yeah and you guys seem to have figured
out that bitching about it isn't the
answer you got to create a parallel
system with fudo um yeah base i mean i
wouldn't say a parallel system certainly
i would like for futo to be a
one of the things about google that is
really nice is just you have so many
smart engineers around you who kind of
know how various things work we would
love for futo to develop into that kind
of organization where you you can
actually quit google and not just be
isolated by yourself
without
without kind of any of that knowledge to
feed off of in your work tell me an
example of like if a developer came to
futo and they started getting involved
what would it be like for them
um well
ideally they would like
say you needed to know how to do some
gpu programming that's very very obscure
and right now only a few people who work
on like low-level android code or who
work at you know qualcomm
know
like there would actually be somebody at
futo that like we would we would have
that they could talk to and like get
that information about how to program
their computer you guys should talk to
james o'keefe
okay
yeah
and then when all the whistleblowers
coming to me just be like right this way
gentlemen here's some jobs would they
like re-um relocate to texas or would
they be able to work remote both both
whatever they yeah it can be virtual and
in person where our headquarters are in
texas though so are you hiring because i
know you mentioned before the show it's
kind of like a y combinator style like
um like um what it's called like
incubator thank you we got we have a
couple of different initiatives on first
we are trying to hire full-time
engineers we have we are first and
foremost an engineering firm we have a
couple of projects underway in-house and
we'd like to have more that's sort of
we're doing for regular hiring like that
we're also doing a y combinator style if
you will grant program this summer in
austin texas it's residential we're
going to have a cool house to stay in
incubator space lots of support
we're going to select three teams of up
to five engineers 20 thousand dollars
for each team member no strings attached
we don't want equity we just want people
working on cool stuff that creates
viable tech alternatives this is so i
want to pull this other story from elon
musk about his his uh his his plans for
a legal effort but we're talking we got
to talk about solutions to you know
what's happening with politics cultural
stuff hearing you guys mention that
you're giving grants to people like just
no strings attached no equity just you
know do the work basically is that what
you're saying yeah if you're working on
something cool man one of the big
challenges when we look at project
veritas james o'keefe comes out he says
be brave
we've got
obviously at these companies their
censorship obviously they're not being
honest we just had this expose where
there's this this uh this engineer
at a twitter talking to his date saying
oh yeah they're censoring the right all
the time
why are these people not coming out and
being like yo they're lying when they go
to congress and say these things they're
lying under oath
i think one of the reasons is they're
scared many people say they say all the
time i got kids man
i can't i can't just up and dip
so
i often talk about infrastructure being
a key element to you know getting away
from silicon valley so rumble for
instance i'm a fan
we use their video player for the
website members only section and we use
their cloud services for our website and
we're integrating more
non-silicon valley infrastructure into
the website we have more plans we'll
announce those as soon as we have them
ready
to create competition to push back
that's another big move
if people are going to be able to blow
the whistle and come out and just give
maybe it's not james o'keefe maybe it's
any any news organization and be like
here's documents proving it there has to
be a place for them to exist there has
to be something telling them you can
find work you can be supported you will
not be thrown to the wolves just by
coming out you're not sacrificing
yourself doing the right thing actually
could benefit you it actually could be
really great for your career all of a
sudden you'll be getting a better job
but i want to pull up this tweet thread
from elon musk from the 20th check this
out
he says tesla is building a hardcore
litigation department where we directly
initiate and execute lawsuits the team
will report directly to me please send
three to five bullet points describing
evidence of exceptional ability justice
tesla.com he says my commitment we will
never seek victory in a just case
against us even if we probably win even
if we will probably win we will never
surrender settle an unjust case against
us even if we will probably lose please
include links to cases you have tried he
says looking for hardcore street
fighters not white shoe lawyers like
perkins or cooley who thrive on
corruption there will be blood
it sounds like he was watching the show
last night
yeah we do well four days ago oh nice
this is this is from four days this is
the sentiment man we need lawyers that
are willing to lose that are willing to
take a chance
this is what one of the things that
frustrates me in in all the the
conversations are people saying there's
oh don't i i've every single time i've
been defamed every time there's been
some question of section 230 every
lawyer i've spoken with has been like
there's no point in trying
don't do it elon musk certainly has the
funds to be like don't know don't care
here's the money have fun
that's what we need we need real
solutions
to all of these issues that are
happening so i'm curious what you guys
think about the legal side of things in
terms of suing or going after you know
we we had talked privately about section
230
i mean i'll defer to ian here who's a
lawyer by training i'm a lawyer by
training i no longer practice so i won't
give direct legal takes but i mean
obviously uh litigation is a huge part
of this you know we just had the um the
fifth circuit rule um in a preliminary
motion in the uh lawsuit to enjoin uh
the um
social media law they passed that could
have a huge impact there's a similar
case on with a similar but not quite as
powerful law in florida that's on i mean
these things are
important in themselves but they're also
the culmination of at this point really
five or six years of litigation around
this very issue around 230 around free
speech around
the power of social media networks and
so on um
and he's absolutely right the entire
industry is coalesced around this and
you have um these industry associations
that are spending a large amount of
money on lawyers to fight because they
do know how how impactful it could be
and you know at fudo we're not directly
involved in any litigation you know we
kind of are focused on the technology
side but we know that it is a
multi-pronged uh fight and those uh
those lawsuits are very important how do
you feel about copyright law from the
past being used
in future tech like with social media
technology and things like that
well okay i'm going to defer to aaron on
intellectual property law in particular
because he has some but i'll just say
that that's been an issue from
uh for 25 years the very first political
issue i ever remember being engaged in
when i was what nine years old or
something was you know the dmca had just
passed uh and if you remember a dcss
uh was a um
a very very simple piece of software
that allowed you to decode a dvd on on a
device without having paid the license
fee for a dvd player uh and this was one
of the first things that they went after
as a
copy uh copyright breaking tool under
the dmca which allowed you to shut it
down and that i mean right there is a um
is a huge that is a use of a copyright
enforcement mechanism uh to um
limit the freedom and uh you know not
necessarily just to protect a copyright
holder but to go after the entire
universe of freely flowing tech of
information and so on and i think that's
a principle that extends more broadly
the same technology that's used to
enforce copyright or intellectual
property can and often is used uh to
enforce
restrictions on free speech on the flow
of information and on the use of
technology in general
that's one of the big challenges with
the copyright stuff that has happened
with social media is i had i had a tweet
that was absolutely fair you get taken
down under copyright and what do you do
there the the challenge is that i kind
of feel like no matter what you do the
person with the most power wins
if you've got the money you're going to
win that's just about it i mean maybe
you might get lucky and and get a good
judge and fight your way through but you
know even in the instance of james
o'keefe fighting defamation cases he
needs to raise like a million two
million dollars to even try to go after
these these big companies and then you
just have the courts are always you know
often siding with the people who are
defaming or the big tech or the
establishment or something like that
this is one of the biggest challenges
that it feels like
even
it feels like fighting an uphill battle
because
uh we you know i've talked about
wikipedia quite a bit
how fractured the system is how it makes
literally no sense but they have so much
money
how do you compete with that as an
individual it just doesn't seem to make
sense you need capital that's for sure
because it's like a war of attrition in
court you it's it's how long can i pay
all these lawyers to stay in this
courthouse and keep talking no one
really cares if they win or lose they're
all getting paid as long as you've got
the money to pay them so you either need
people to work for free which is a form
of capital or money social currency
getting a lot of people who believe in
you just to you know focus fire their
efforts and their and their labor
towards something more powerful i guess
i wanna i wanna i wanna mention an idea
to you so uh ian you're you're a lawyer
by training i wanna ask your thoughts on
this
what if we made a uh
a website
where as soon as you load it you are
placed in a queue where you can write
one word
and 5 000 people all write one word
who's sued for defamation when you write
a story claiming that nancy pelosi eats
dogs
it's a tough one i see what you're
getting in here that you know what
you're running there's an interactive
computer service which is protected from
defamation under uh you know cda section
two each individual made no statement
right writing the word dog i didn't say
anything all i wrote was dog you can't
sue me can you
it's a very interesting like that could
be a good
law school hypothetical right
we need some coders
if you're a developer we're going to
create this interactive website
where uh it starts with a queue i
mentioned this the other day and then
everyone from you from your position you
know you like if you're the first person
in you're number one you get the first
word
we'll just let everybody like fork it
whenever they want and you'll be
guaranteed to get whatever whatever
you want and then as an editor you can
pick the one that you want to show
exactly and then we'll feature whichever
one that comes up so you might have an
article that says like nancy pelosi run
jump car drive fast and you're just like
that's nonsense and then you'll finally
get one that says nancy pelosi ate a dog
because people just did
mad libs
yeah kind of digital madness every
single word
what if you tell them this has to be a
verb then are you all suddenly an editor
then you'll get sued because you're
telling them to write a verb or a noun
because that'll help it that's
interesting
i think we're onto something i mean what
if i wrote nancy pelosi what if we did
an actual ad-lib
know mad lib or whatever it's called
where it's like nancy pelosi blanked a
blank and then some random person could
put a word and i didn't write the
sentence right i put blanks someone else
put it can you would i be able to be
sued for defamation
uh
i'm not definitely not an expert in
defamation law it seems it seems like a
difficult case to me you know it's gonna
it's gonna hinge in a lot of things that
but yeah i'm
it's interesting i mean the problem is
your your website it would be hard for
you to get enough clout for your website
for people to you know believe
what it's said as opposed to wikipedia
where it kind of has a lot of clout now
sure sure i just think you know we'll be
allowed to post all this stuff sure like
i'll put it on twitter to a million 1.3
million people and let him share it and
then what is anyone going to say to me
they're going to be like you can't say
that and i'll be like i'm just sharing a
story from you know people you can't sue
me for it it's not my i'll i'll tweet it
out and i'll put what a crazy story
right and then everyone will see the
headline and uh
and then what can i do about it there's
a question whether it's definitely like
if it is a website where these things
truly are random people posting words i
think there's some question as to
whether it is actually even if it is
something nasty that comes up eventually
uh as to whether it is like defamation
you know as opposed to people would not
take it and if no one would take it as
such
you know
you know there's a certain point at
which it's obviously satire and not not
meant as a statement
what if i only allowed
a handful of words like nancy
pelosi
eats and dog
dog eats nancy pelosi you sure yeah yeah
whatever whatever whatever combination
of the words love you nancy i'm just
kidding what if it turns out to be true
that's the real
that's the
yeah you got to be careful i don't know
i'm i'm crying i'm joking but i mean i
just i look at what's going on with big
tech and how they're basically
invincible how they have these laws that
for us we get spat on we get pissed on
we get stepped on
and then wikipedia can just do whatever
the hell they want
that that that can't be that that just
cannot be it's when it says from
wikipedia that it starts to get real
fishy for me like if it was if they were
clear like this is all community and
they they linked to the the screen names
of the people that put the little pieces
in and stuff that's a different story
except
someone could write on wikipedia nancy
pelosi eats chicken
another person can go in and change
chicken to dog and they've made no
statement you can't sue that person
because they've made no statement the
person who said she eat chicken maybe
that's true the person who changed
chicken a dog did not make a statement
he just said the word dog you can't sue
someone for saying a single word there's
no defamation there wikipedia needs to
be sued into oblivion because it is them
they have automated the editorial
process under their own byline and this
this argument that they're protecting
under section 230 makes absolutely no
sense
you know what
we need so how do we how do we do this
do we set up a go well go give send go
raise a couple million bucks find
someone with standing and say have fun
is that is that allowed is that legal
i mean you've had i mean my my
preference would be to solve this
technically and like build a better
product than wikipedia
but it's
see i just i disagree i think culture is
the issue
that regular people know wikipedia use
wikipedia google has integrated
wikipedia and every facet this machine
is here and they are clearly violating
at the very least the spirit of the law
but i believe technically like in a
technical standpoint they're they're you
know totally open to being sued someone
just needs to
do it
where's james o'keefe someone called me
called the children
i mean there's been lawsuits right so i
mean
they happen and wikipedia will settle
i just we need wikipedia will change it
even if i feel they have to well they
should change it i mean that's the goal
right get him to change it so they stop
allowing this because right now
i do not understand how wikipedia can
can publish such false statements i mean
look
the the project veritas article
wikipedia is clearly an opinion piece
it's it's outrageous how much opinion it
is
they they're this that or otherwise and
conspiracies and it's it's loaded with
fake news it's loaded with provenly
false claims
and it's from wikipedia james you gotta
sue maybe we shouldn't be able to have
people on wikipedia they shouldn't you
shouldn't be able to have a person's
page or a corporations page on wikipedia
because like in encyclopedia britannica
they didn't have like people it would
just be things
well i mean you had i think i think
there's maybe no living people at some
point don't i'm not actually sure about
that but i think maybe at some point it
was no living people but i i could be
wrong okay
i just i mean you've had larry singer on
i mean he's working on this we're
actually futo is did a grant for his
organization to try to fix this
i i i kind of agree with you like like
wikipedia owns the culture right now and
like
it's great it's hard to solve like still
like you know this is a hard work and
like as futile as a tech organization we
want to try to create technical
solutions i do feel like there is some
ways we can chip away at wikipedia
clearly free speech has already weakened
their stature in the culture there's
many people who like know that
wikipedia's propaganda
on any kind of contentious issue what i
would like to see as from the technical
solution would be some sort of way for
dissenting editors at wikipedia to very
very easily fork it and
have their own kind of wiki have their
own articles show up and have you know
building this product is one of the
trickier i consider wikipedia to be a
very special case of social media it's
crowdsourced it's a bunch of editors
like you said making diffs to articles
right but it still is very much you know
crowdsourced from millions of people or
hundreds of thousands of people it all
comes in
how can we get get it so that like
those contributions are more
uh ubiquitous for the world and like
different editors can decide different
editor organizations can decide who
which editor should be banned and which
shouldn't and the dissenting side in any
kind of these wikipedia edit wars
actually has
a viable thing that people will find and
that's that's those are the sorts of
things that larry's working on
with this his organization you could
have like a page with all these overlays
that would pop up with different
percentages of how accurate or each
overlay relative to these editors like
if an editor has a 72 rating then
they're gonna affect their overlay that
they edited and then you'd be able to
sort all the overlays on like dog the
wikipedia thing of like hillary clinton
or whatever right and then so you'd see
like 900 000 hillary clinton wikipedia
pages on top of each other and then
you'd sort them by the ones with the
most trusted editors and you sort that
one to the top
maybe i think the issue is the most
trusted editors would be 50 50 if that
right so
i once i was talking with a group of
people way back in the day about a a
journalist rating system or a news
organization rating system one of the
things we want to do with our our fact
checking nonprofit is create a browser
extension and then actually hire the
fact checker hire fact checkers to do to
rate various news outlets based on
violations of journalistic ethics one of
the ideas has always been what if you
create a meter showing like how much do
we trust a journalist
okay well if they write for breitbart
they're going to get a zero right
because every mainstream every liberal
democrat person is going to be like liar
liar liar liar liar at best you could
hope for 50 50. but that means
you need like
if i came out
and said joe biden uh is corrupt
you know has engaged in overt corruption
with the ukraine scandal saying fire the
prosecutor i mean that is a statement of
fact
when they claimed that donald trump was
trying to get a quid pro quo in ukraine
joe biden did literally that going going
to the president saying fire the
prosecutor or you're not getting a
billion dollars in loan guarantees it's
exactly what they claimed it was so it's
corruption he's just not been held
accountable for it if i say that people
on the left are going to say either
knowingly
that uh or i should say that willfully
they'll call me a liar knowing it's true
because they want political power so
they'll say oh that story from tim pool
is false minus one then you're gonna get
a bunch of other democrats and antitypes
are gonna be like that's not true i
heard on cnn minus one
you're hoping then that if a thousand of
these people right down rate you
that some conservative who knows it's
true is going to uprate you or at the
very least you'll end up with
conservatives saying i believe that's
true whether it is or not it's going to
be the inverse version of the same thing
so we need a trustless way to identify
their value um maybe if people don't
realize their rating the articles or the
individuals that edit the articles but
they're they're either maybe with with
crypto
um i like the trustless
smart
contracts i'm kind of throwing out buzz
words here i gotta i gotta be a little
more uh pessimistic though i think the
issue is culture it doesn't matter if
you're gonna say a journalist is trusted
or not what matters is what the culture
wants believes and expects and right now
we have two very distinct cultures in
this country that will never come
together i think it's natural resistance
is natural human um evolution it's part
of our evolution our nature you'll
always have people saying that you're
wrong and always at people saying you're
right for the most part things are
things are different i mean
it used to be that there were democrats
and republicans they'd argue with each
other but they were all americans they'd
all come out for the fourth of july and
be like oh you know i don't agree with
that stuff but hey america america right
now you've got people
that cnn for instance all these big news
outlets know for a fact they're never
going to sell to a trump supporter so
they have absolutely zero reason to be
honest about trump and his supporters if
they know their bread is being buttered
by a bunch of you know left activists
why would they ever tell the truth on
trump
i mean right now jim acosta you know he
did a segment the other day where he
claimed donald trump appears to have
been calling for civil war
which is just bs it's not true trump
retweeted basically a guy who said the
words civil war i don't know what that
means
it's like you on the news story here's
the facts
donald trump reposts
comment that says civil war that's it
take for it what you will that's the
fact the opinion is was he calling for
it was he predicting it was he scared i
have no idea but jim acosta cnn all
these big mainstream outlets say he's
either calling for it or predicting it
that's not true none of that is true
that's all opinion but they know
there's no one
for the most part who is buying from
them for truth
everybody wants their their confirmation
bias everyone no matter where you come
from now i think there's a tendency more
so on the right to associate with those
who are right
you know post liberals moderates
libertarians conservatives whatever the
freedom spaces
you have more people who are like no no
just tell me what's true
the left for the most part has gone full
zealot as far as i can tell
i don't like the word true truth anymore
i i used to be a zealot about what was
true and i'd be like it is this the one
true something and i was like come on
iam you don't know like get over
yourself and also the word trust i don't
think humans trust each other we're wild
animals we've domesticated each other we
kind of sit in peace together with like
pretending like we know we're not gonna
hurt each other but like doesn't mean
it's never going to happen you know
so we live in this idea of truth and
trust which is just like
100 percent there are extremes that
don't exist and so we should code our
stuff that way too and trust can be can
be in a way counterproductive let me
explain that just briefly the um i
talked to several people who grew up
behind the iron curtain and what they
always say about that is you know we
knew our news was fake we knew the
newspapers were nonsense but uh and in a
way that's sort of because there was no
trust they knew that okay you have to
read between the lines you have to
really think about this
in this uh in this country
um for better or for worse we used to
have much more trust in media and our
institutions i think part of that is
technological you know that we had an
era where the main means of media
distribution were the broadcast
television channels a few major
newspapers that were sort of
had a a legal interest in being
i i don't want to use the word objective
that that strongly but uh new more
neutral
and we don't have that and we sort of
carried over this uh unwarranted trust
and as that's that's broken down i think
people look at things even even
wikipedia i think with a with a more
skeptical eye
um
and you know if you can shore that up
the people's uh you know you can find
things that people can trust i think you
do you do a service
i like well i think trustless they talk
about like um
like smart contracts crypto smart
contracts or trust lists because you
don't have to trust that giving your
money to the guy he's gonna do the thing
that you gave him the money to do it
just automatically happens so you remove
that that level of trust
um
like
i get like trusting your parents if you
don't trust your parents i mean
the world's gonna seem like it wants to
kill you every moment you're you're
living in it but if you can trust your
parents it's still like doesn't mean
they're never going to turn on you but
it's just like
an acceptance like when i step on my
foot's not going to go through the
ground i trust that i'm going to land on
solid ground
um i guess it's just not an ideal like
like
what do we have to trust something every
individual should be allowed to decide
on their own who they trust right i mean
based on what parameters everybody gets
to decide through their interactions
with them right it's not we can't have a
top-down approach to trust where we're
told to trust certain people i kind of
feel like there there may be an
inevitability in the hyperpolarization
though i think it's possible that the
tech oligarchs the censorship has
exacerbated this by banning only some
people
i kind of feel like
we saw early on in the internet
tribes were forming where people like to
rag on each other there's a video that i
talk about often called this video will
make you angry by cgp gray where he
mentions that communities don't actually
argue with each other they argue amongst
themselves about the other and they get
riled up and get angrier and angrier
about it and this tribalism eventually
leads to conflict so i wonder if
if
do you think that's an inevitability
in in it with the internet i mean the
culture war itself arising out of these
tribes that have formed everyone hates
each other i mean yeah i mean human
nature we see it with sports teams
everything like it's it's inevitable but
it doesn't
how do you stop it from getting to the
point where people are killing each
other this this is a philosophical point
but i think that um yes if you do have
uh i don't know if you call it a free
market for but if you do have uh
different groups able to trust who they
want
uh and and able to to
use an alternative technology when they
want to get the information they do i
think that you have
i understand that that can lead to
problems but i think it leads to fewer
problems than
one of uh like you say this top down
enforcement of trust where inevitably
one tribe or one side or another is
going to feel this intense resentment
i think that's when things get really
dangerous when people
are confirmed in their belief that
they're that
everything is against them well let's
talk about this we got a story from the
independent
put people in jail former fox reporter
calls for arrests over right wing's
great replacement theory tucker carlson
responded saying this is going to get
really ugly really soon
slamming x-fox news colleague who
suggested he should be in jail or
something worse
what's something worse carlson asked his
audience after hearing a clip of the
remarks from the former reporter cameron
made uh over the weekend at cnn we're
not sure what something worse is but it
certainly feels like we're moving toward
it at a very high speed at this point
rhetoric has its own internal logic
we've experienced it we can talk
ourselves into things democrats are
doing it right now and what they're
talking themselves into right now is
quote something worse it's scary it's
time to pull back it's time to
de-escalate otherwise this is going to
get really ugly really soon
so um you know should i say the magic
word civil war
you can always say i mean i would i
would hope that everybody ignores um
people like that on the extreme they
don't right i mean some people do some
people don't right like you know i have
my friends from silicon valley are all
democrats but they're not going to say
carlson should be executed for talking
about replacement theory
but are they uh are they active in
politics are they the the public
speakers
no exactly so you have on cnn here's
what happens i i don't think intent
matters on either side as this conflict
escalates this guy goes on cnn they
probably didn't know he was going to say
this he says it they probably say okay
well that's a little over the top but
you know we know we don't mean it right
we don't we don't want to go that far
but then tucker carlson sees it and then
he talks about it and says look what
they're doing look what they're saying
and then of course people who see that
are like whoa those people are crazy so
it's it's it's exacerbating the problem
it's escalating things regardless of
whether they're being tongue-in-cheek or
hyperbolic or otherwise
feels like the network should be
responsible for these people that are
talking on the network i know it's not a
social network so if they don't have
i don't know 230
imperative but they don't they don't
they don't care though because they know
they don't make money from trump
supporters they have no cultural tie to
conservatives republicans or
libertarians but this guy's saying
something worse the only thing worse
than jail for a criminal is death
penalty that i'd know of i mean
life in prison or death penalty that's
the next thing that's worse uh so what's
this guy going cnn and suggesting that
someone needs the death penalty for
talking on a news channel and now people
are going to hear you needs to come out
and say speak against that and so
whether whether uh
anyone has the full intent of it or not
people will hear us talking about it
right and they're going to be like man
these cnn people have lost their minds
allowing this yeah they say ian's right
they shouldn't allow that this guy's
calling for the death penalty for tucker
carlson that's crazy and then you'll
mention my democrat friends don't
believe that but this is something at
the highest level of the conversation
right right i would say that
you know it's kind of all of our
collective responsibility to do what you
can i mean i i do what i can to keep my
democrat friends a lot of them you know
i'm an independent and i've still lost a
lot of
friends you know just by being a little
bit more outspoken
but try to make an effort to stay
friends with people they're most people
are reasonable like and you know if you
point out things like this to them
they'll probably be yeah that's bat [ __ ]
crazy i didn't i thought all the bat
[ __ ] crazy people were on the right i
didn't realize there were bat [ __ ] crazy
people on my side too
yeah uh it was part in the french oh
i'll do it i'll do a little bit uh
try and do a little a little bit of that
reconciliation say look what he said is
is is totally legal i mean what he's
suggesting is ridiculous and
unconstitutional and a million other
things but
you know him saying that that should be
the penalty for saying things he doesn't
you know believe or
should be said on on public error i mean
i guess you can say that how does he get
to that point how does this guy get to
the point where we'd actually say
something worse than jailing for talking
about
an idea pushed by so i just want to
clarify he should lose his job i don't
know he said he'd go to jail or
something like a jail for a week or lose
your job i don't know i wouldn't
apologize for it i'm not what i would
what i would say is these people
i'm sorry i i don't know how we solve
this because i think they're nuts and
i'll tell you why
it has been many prominent democrats who
have argued for demographic change in an
effort to maintain power
when tucker carlson points that out they
accuse him of pushing a conspiracy
theory and i'll say it again many
democrats have said
immigration is a path towards
maintaining political power
tucker carlson says look what they're
saying he shows them saying it and they
say he has said something so dangerous
he should be jailed or something worse
how do they get to that point
i look i know donald trump said locker
up to hillary clinton
right maybe that's it maybe maybe it's
inevitable hillary clinton actually did
bad things
joe biden did bad things
yeah but political persecution is not
the answer that's for so what what do
you do then do you say hillary clinton
destroyed 30 000 emails but we're not
going to go after her because it would
he should he should say she should be
charged not locked up that's the judge
to decide or the jury
and then everyone says criminally charge
my opponent you criminally charge yours
everyone says they're right you know you
mentioned it on the show before the left
says the exact same thing about us that
we say about them and then i pointed out
yeah but we're right
like we when i say joe biden
went to the pro went to the president of
ukraine and said if you don't fire the
prosecutor not getting the billion
dollar loan guarantees that's on video
he actually did that a prosecutor who
was investigating barisma where his son
was on the board all of that happened
well that should be investigated but
then they pushed things like the ahmed
arbory lie the guy who filmed it goes to
prison you know trayvon martin george
floyd i mean all of these things that
were embellished hands up don't shoot
outright not true jesse smilet they all
believed it they keep pushing all these
things that are just outright falsehoods
but you have it's it's almost like man
an equal and opposite reaction as more
people get access to the truth through
social media more people join the
zealous cult as a as an equal and
opposite reaction is that really it is
there is there is the is that law of
thermodynamics just a reality for every
element of existence we have free will
it exists within our energy but we have
free will like when something i think
that people are doing too much these
days too fast with politics like you
don't need to make a change like today
we're like what's going on with the news
there's not a lot of news today good
let's live in peace that's the idea
and and these feelings like they got to
legislate and create new law new law and
new lawn sign this and that like dude
what
maybe it's like that um that episode of
star trek
where bellat which one is that is the
half white half black no no no
where they're uh they have this this
energy pulse slamming into the the
enterprise and so they're like raise the
shields and then they're like the energy
pulse is getting stronger and they keep
doing it and then finally i think it's
uh was it data or somebody says lower
the shields and they're like are you
sure do it and they do and then the
energy wave dissipates and it was that
the more they increase their shields the
more the refl the energy reflected back
stronger
like it like a chinese finger trap
you've got to stop pulling as hard as
you can and just push in
then you can get your fingers out become
friends with your enemy and all of a
sudden there's no conflict
but i i wonder if right at the point
where the finger trap has been ripped to
shreds and there's no you know coming
back i mean one of the things i you know
when when people were really fighting in
2020 i was like well let's do tulsi
gabbard like she would be like the
compromise candidate for both parties
and what on both sides and what happened
with the left
yeah the
when i suggested this my uh some of my
friends
uh on facebook went ape [ __ ] saying she
was just a uh
an evil republican yeah this is why i i
say like
you know when you say the left does the
same thing about us i'm like yes but
we're right it's very simple because i'm
not a traditional conservative i've
never been a conservative and i
supported yang and tulsi in 2020 trying
to find that compromise that the
establishment left and the leftists were
unwilling to have so some of my friends
were receptive to it too too though so i
mean yeah just keep trying but i think i
think those for sure for sure i think a
lot of people who watch this show even
were probably like oh yeah i used to
vote democrat then we started paying
attention and now we're just like i'm
not interested i'm not saying
republicans are going to solve your
problems i don't think they are i think
they're going to do a lot of nothing i
like your metaphor about the shields
creating more than the finger trap
because it's like if you're angry about
what you're communicating because you've
been upset by what they did then people
can tell and they don't want to listen
but if you're if you don't have that
resistance and you're just stating it
yeah biden you know he bribed those guys
to to fire that prosecutor so that he
charisma didn't get investigated that's
pretty much that's that's a fact i saw
on tv
i should say i'm not mad about it it
happened
why did biden do it well we can say it
it's corruption either way because
telling a foreign country that you will
withhold aid to them unless they fire
someone that's a corrupt act he doesn't
have the authority to do that and they
even told him that he bragged about it
and said call the president see what he
says like wow he's bragging about
superseding the will of the people
that's crazy now did he do it to protect
his son
that's a question needs to be an answer
to an investigation what do we know
the prosecutor was investigating barisma
his son was on the board joe biden did
intervene you don't talk about motives
or incentives i don't care he did it
so
now you investigate look into emails
determine whether or not he did it to
protect his son or not but either way
like he bragged about doing it now when
we say that
who's telling the truth i mean that's a
conversation i had with my dad a couple
a few days ago about the facts cause he
was like when he watches the show from
time to time he's like oh you there you
guys are saying wrong the wrong
information is what you're saying is
wrong and i'm like well what's right
what's true there's so much information
being shoved into and he was actually
like but i mean what's true how do you
know what's true you get 80 million
different pieces of information from 80
million different sources and and
they're all they're all
like they might be right they might be
wrong so it's like we get we get things
wrong yeah
the things we get wrong aren't like core
details on major political events the
things we get wrong are like i'll i'll
say a caliber of a gun and then someone
will chat be like tim you're wrong about
that it's actually this i'm like oh that
was a mistake yeah but to them you're in
the same category as qnon people who
believe all sorts of crazy stuff right
and we're not right but that's not what
they that's not how they see it but they
are
the the the blue and on people and q
anon people they they they would get
along seemingly in their weird beliefs
and things that aren't true yeah you
tend to see in others what's in you but
look q anon is fringe
mainstream conservatives and
libertarians aren't entertaining kunan
people
blue anon
is mainstream democrat they believe for
years the ukraine gate russia gate stuff
that's all been debunked
yeah i mean i agree like
you know i would say
in silicon valley the republicans
justifiably lost like any support for
the future with like cheney and bush
and i would say the same thing today
that like the democrats have equally
deserved like no support in the future
from any of these if anybody who's
principled i would say quit what
concerns you quit your party if you're
democrat but if you go to
your average republican and ask them
about some crazy conspiracy
they might give you a half-baked answer
where it's like well i don't know but
you know these things i think are weird
and i read this somewhere if you go to
your mainstream democrat and ask them
about like russia and stuff they're
probably going to be like yeah i think
he did it
sure and it's like even though mueller
proved it wasn't true even though now
with the sussman trial we're learning
about hillary clinton's role in in
signing off on these things they're
going to be like i don't know about that
i mean first of all i'm still manning my
friends just here just so you know but
um you know they would say
well yeah we know that the there we know
that there was all this stuff that's
like shady about the the report um
that came came out of england or
whatever
but we still know that there's like
collusion happening between trump and
trump and russia like we know that he
has hotel deals he wants in moscow and
and they'll say stuff like that and you
know to some degree you know
there's probably you know
there's you know you can't be as
successful as donald trump was without
you know having to bend the law a little
bit i think
for sure you know and so we we we talk
about uh trump and the things we
actually don't like about his presidency
relatively often drone strikes and you
know why that happened
things like that um donald trump whether
it was him or or someone else trump
hotels were being advertised on a state
department website like these are bad
things trump tried to have i think the
g7 at trump doral in florida like really
bad thing you shouldn't do it and trump
was like but i'm gonna do it at cost and
i said so what you're still maintaining
your business through a government
contract i think that's wrong i got no
problem saying that but then you hear
from a lot of these people
they won't even bother watching a show
like this i mean let alone google
searching half the news that comes out
that to me
i'm sorry if i'm a little pessimistic in
that regard but i think you know we talk
about technology and all these things
and i don't think that's the issue i do
think
we need technology to be developed
because there may come a time when we
get cut off completely from silicon
valley
if a civil war really is coming
or we're in one fourth fifth
generational warfare whatever it may be
what do you think is going to happen to
the anti-establishment
when
states start breaking apart
san francisco is going to be like
eliminate all the ips from states that
we don't like and then how will you
communicate what will you be using
there's going to need to be something
so that that in that sense technology
that's why i you know i like rumble
cloud service because i'm like
they might censor me so what you said
earlier aaron was interesting that um
silicon valley people there got
disenfranchised with the republicans
with bush and cheney and then now
they're being disenfranchised with this
ridiculousness in the democrats side i
hope so i mean that would be my hope i'm
not there anymore so but what the
problem with that is that who who they
care about now while they care about the
corporation so who's the new authority
the corporation i mean if google thinks
it's running the show now because the
court the politicians are incompetent
that's kind of like maybe even worse i
don't know what's worse an incompetent
president or a corporation that thinks
it's in charge
i don't know that's a good question um i
would hope that there's still
anti-corporation too i mean the left was
supposed to always be anti-corporation
like from
from my entire life and so yeah it's uh
it's another pro corporate i can't even
stop at google it's alphabet which is
owned by blackrock i mean it's not it's
it's in part owned by blackrock state
street vanguard yeah and that is that is
purely a result of the propaganda to
like try to scare people about like you
know the corporations are only hope
against these evil racists in kentucky
or whatever who you know are gonna you
know would be throwing gay people off of
buildings if they had their way um
so
yeah well now there's like a big scandal
in the uk because they they were flying
the union jack over some street
and all these leftists are like this is
what the nazis did and it's like yo it's
your country's flag
like just because the nazis drank water
doesn't mean you shouldn't drink water
you know i'm thinking about possobic i
don't know if you guys heard jack
posobik he was in uh it went to davos a
couple days ago and was detained by by
klaus schwab's personal guard i don't
know if they were they're private
players i believe yeah were they private
police no the swiss police it looks like
they were just kind of i was told they
were private i could be wrong okay maybe
they were they were wearing police on
their yeah so maybe it was maybe it was
police maybe it was corporate security i
don't know they were wearing police on
their uniforms yeah
so maybe it was swiss police let's just
stop there then i don't know for sure if
it was if it was a private guard but uh
you know you see this corporate private
guard
and they don't care about the law they
care about serving the corporation where
they get paid
that's uh that's where i think that's
the fear i'm not so worried about the
politics i'm worried about these
corporations that are sneaking and
trying to buy up land
bill gates
what is the single largest owner of
farmland that doesn't mean he owns
all of the farmland it means for a
single entity he owns more than anybody
else
that's a lot
it's weird
i don't trust the guy yeah i don't want
to pile on the guy but man he is he is a
woman where's luke at he's coming we
need him to hear you luke
is luke in the chat i don't know
probably hi luke if you're watching
luke rodkowski ladies and gentlemen we
are change big fan
yeah i mean it's it's funny how you have
uh
you have this belief
or i don't know how you describe it but
um
you have multinational corporations
politicians they meet together in big
international conferences the new york
times are invited guests of at the world
economic forum along with world leaders
and people like bill gates where they're
talking about really horrifying things
like
what do they say implantable biotracking
or whatever for your lives tracking your
carbon footprint yeah for for better
compliance
yep
they talk about like mandating health
requirements stuff it's so crazy because
it's not american i for a while it was
like i just disbelieve it i couldn't
even begin to believe that people
thought that way because i'm like no i'm
born in america first amendments is
paramount you don't do that that to
people that doesn't happen but now i'm
real saying they're not from america
they're not from the united they don't
think like that this is like
authoritarian weird european
pseudo-communist fascist nazi stuff
freaking and technocratic yeah there are
misconceptions sorry good no there are
misconceptions about just how popular
like the um i i hate the term free
speech absolutism because it kind of
begs the question but the american first
amendment conception of free speech is
not unique in the world but it's very
rare uh and and i think
one of my worries is that i think it's
actually becoming increasingly rare just
in a gut conception of what free speech
is in the younger generation and
millennials now gen z is even more so
um
and to address what you're saying is the
government the worst is the
corporation's the worst
i i would split the difference and say
the worst possible state of affairs uh
is one where they're both both the
government and corporations are
competing to please each other that you
have in place uh a corporate apparatus
that can do things that a state would
like it to do
without repercussions so i wanna people
are saying that the police actually were
wearing badges that said world economic
forum police on their arms
so that's actually what jack he said to
their world economic forum police so
it's a private company and it's they
have the word police on it which is
interesting because i used to think of
police as a public
service but not in switzerland
apparently i would i mean it's not
surprising in switzerland no it's not
but i better doubt man
that was a big blizzard it was crazy
everybody everybody was there was like
betting on crypto for the future all
these ultra rich people yeah you guys
got deep in crypto
uh not really no um
i mean crypto is something we've been
looking at a lot
recently
it's actually
it's been overhyped and we're kind of
disappointed that
we wanted to find a lot of
anti-establishment engineers to kind of
just make these kind of decentralized
things and open source things that you
know
help free us from the oligopoly and
unfortunately a lot of the attention
you know i i like to say you know all
the elite engineers are either working
for google
but those who aren't are working for uh
they're trying to do cryptocurrency
schemes um and
some of them are you know bitcoin works
you know it's great a lot of these
things are just complete nonsense
they're they don't work they're not
going to work
i remember in the early days
some of them yeah i remember in the
early days
there were just
hundreds of coins that were derivative
of bitcoin
and people were just trading between
them and it was nonsense it was like
they were all basically just slight
alterations of bitcoin for some reason
people bought the craziest thing
was when there would be a coin
that was the lowest possible value it
could be
like
an you know eighth decimal point of a
cent
so if you bought a ton of it it could
only double
so people would do it so people would
put like a thousand bucks into the most
worthless thing possible because the
very least you sold it and got your
money back because it couldn't go any
lower
it's the weirdest thing and then if it
went up to two
you doubled your money and you pulled
out
crazy back in the day with crypto it was
just weird stuff came a hot potato ponzi
schemes whatever yeah you need utility i
like the mines coin as an example
because you use one coin on the mines
network to get a thousand views of
advertising
yeah bill's been really good about
making sure mines is like not a not like
what i was talking about like it's
you know
not treated more seriously than it
should be and it's kind of useful they
didn't take a pre-sale like the ceo
didn't take 20 of the coins before they
went live they just all went live he
buys them just like everyone else he has
to get them just like everyone else does
that's a legitimate thing and then they
won't nail it as a securities fraud it's
not a ponzi scheme it actually has value
on the network
but then do you need crypto
well you gotta you gotta be able to
defend yourself against the swift
payment system if they want to cut off
your bank account i don't know if you
need crypto necessarily but couldn't you
just make like
the mines coin you know facebook did
this before remember when they tried
making their own currency
yeah i mean they did try and telegram
did too no no even before libra i'm
pretty sure they'd like facebook coin or
something oh yeah before crypto
they were like tokens you could get for
like the games or whatever i mean yeah
that's just that's not even a blockchain
that's just right no it's like it's like
an in-app purchase in a video game like
yeah and it's like having gems and zelda
you know but you can use them on
facebook
yeah
so understanding diablo uh diablo 2 gold
was actually like a usable currency in
some countries for a while
oh yeah world of warcraft gold also
that actually had value because they
were you know people wanted it so they
were farming it and selling it but now
world of warcraft allows you to just buy
you know buy gold you buy a token that
gives someone a month of gameplay and
then they spend 20 000 gold on it so
then the economy is totally manipulated
you know i just want to say this guys
if uh if you like
if you're not a fan of communism
if you want to explain inflation to
somebody just in introduce them to world
of warcraft or if you know any
socialists who play just ask them have
they ever noticed why it makes no sense
that linen costs like
30 gold
so let me let me simplify this for you
guys
you don't need to be a fan of video
games or anything like that for to
understand what's important or how it's
a good you know reference for people
in the early days of world of warcraft
there's a game mechanic secondary class
uh secondary
i'll call professions
so um when you go out and you're
fighting bandits and then they die you
take their clothes you get linen cloth
you can then use that cloth to make
armor or you can do leather working you
you kill a boar and then you skin it
take its leather
it used to be worthless
because the the value of the item you
got was comparable to the level you were
if you just started the game and it's
easy to kill these things it's not very
valuable now is it
but then they rolled out the mass
printing of currency by allowing you to
buy money so if you start the game you
can be like i want to buy the best item
so i'm going to give hard us cash to
just have all the gold i want without
doing any work for it
well what ends up happening is
now the lowest level items cost obscene
amounts of money if you start the game
off you'll have no way of making that
money i guess you it's hyperinflation
you get the land and then you sell it
for a bunch of money and then the
economy makes literally no sense anymore
that's what the mass printing of money
does makes everything cost more and
world of warcraft is the easiest way to
make these young gen z or millennial
socialists understand it let's go to
super chats
if you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com we have a members only
show coming up at 11 p.m tonight and uh
let's read what y'all got to say
mr swaggerwagon says is it possible for
you to get elon on the podcast i would
trade the entirety of my wealth for that
episode gotta have ian also those two
dudes having a talk would be priceless
uh
your name is
iran yes it's not elon no but do you
know him i do not know him all right
yeah i want to talk to him about
terraforming mars i've got some ideas
about like magnetic transportation
between orbital platforms talk about
like regrowing the uh
the coral in the ocean by with
microfragmentation and stuff i think
it'll be a great conversation you know
you know it would be a really
interesting conversation if you're
serious it's why we haven't gotten
starlink yet oh yeah um apparently it's
not quite working if you're like
uh on the road yet but those aren't
their names announced it
uh starlink for rv as they announced so
i i'm subscribed to residential business
and rv and i'm like where's it at come
on they said that it works best if the
rv is parked if you're driving that it
cuts in and out yeah still but that's
not the intention but i'm just saying
you know
we'll get elon in the show and i'll just
be like where's my starlink
no i tweeted at him come on the show
bring starling
okay good yeah yeah he's not gonna do it
i'd love to see it too yeah yeah
i don't know man maybe whenever it's up
to elon we're gonna terraform mars dude
we're gonna melt all that ice underneath
the iron rich uh dust that's gonna then
fertilize the ocean and regrow plankton
there's no atmosphere not yet all of
that water will just drift off into
space i wonder yes i wonder how much ice
there is there it'll all go off in outer
space i don't know yes yeah i think it
got hit and slowed down mars you need a
certain amount of gravity to hold an
atmosphere in
so if uh i i could be completely wrong
about this but i was reading about why
we can't colonize more i'm actually more
bullish on on what they call the o'neill
cylinder which is like you know the
hollowed-out asteroid that's rotating
and you could do that in low-earth orbit
and it won't be like you won't have
deaths when people like have problems on
mars like because they can just get to
earth pretty quickly but you do have a
habitat
like that's exterior from the earth
ecosystem we just saw we just need
faster than light travel
you know can we we need to figure out
how to rip holes in the fabric of
space-time i think it's the al coubier
drive it's a warp drive technology yeah
i mean look
we need more people like elon who are
like trying to get stuff done yeah
because like if we're just going to wait
for
faster than light travel is probably not
going to be something we get
um
star trek tech is probably not going to
be something we get so but i definitely
would love to get off this planet like i
was always a big fan of star trek um
yeah but if we we should just do what we
can with what we know now
if we do if we do colonize mars it's
going to be underground or it's going to
be big domes you won't go outside
it's going to be controlled environments
inside
uh
yeah if we do seed bombing you retrofit
c60 bomber planes or like drones and you
can drop like a billion seeds per day of
trees and like they don't they don't
catch like if you're doing it by hand
but so many of them land and if we can
start growing trees there's no
atmosphere yeah but if there's there's
carbon dioxide coming out of the watt
there's not enough gravity to hold the
atmosphere in get it yeah i'm wondering
if so it just goes off into space the
the dust the the soil or whatever you
want to call it the substrate is also
drier i think than any any desert on
earth by a factor of like you know three
times or something that needs to be
heated up so that ice melts now venus
that's what i'm talking about yeah uh
like cloud city and empire strikes
exactly yeah they talk about how because
there's very dense gases you can
actually build easily floating cities
oh yeah i shouldn't say easily but like
they're like it's a cinch
you hollow out large structures and then
you vacuum it out so they float like
boats above the desert and you can now
you have one atmosphere of pressure and
you have actually one gravity close to
one gravity so it's much much more
hospitable than mars i think will ever
be all right let's read some more
we got ian holly's head he said civil
war drink that's right
say it ten more times if you're really
gonna take shots civil war
texas ranger says tim should we bring
back asylums to lock up those with
mental illness who are a threat to
themselves and others
i mean we still lock up people who are
threat to themselves another's called
the 51 50. my parents met at a mental
institution
that explains it they worked there
they worked there they got married in
the chapel there it sounded so much
different than the way the first way
everyone's like now we understand
all right andy steli says what is your
opinion on teachers conceal carrying
only a good guy with a gun can stop a
bad guy with a gun
lids the lids is the reason tim cast
works shouts
uh
i think everybody has a right to keep in
bear arms doesn't matter if a teacher or
not janitor or whatever
even the kids
i don't own guns but i like that my
neighbors own guns like i'd much
yeah
does the constitution set an age limit
for any of the amendments
do 12 year olds not have a first
amendment right serious question i think
they do
they they do some places and they don't
other there's a case about the first
amendment rights of students in schools
what about fourth amendment
um
all at least in the context of school
that uh they had their fourth amendment
rights are somewhat different there are
there are cases i mean they still have a
fourth amendment right but it is
reasonable to search them in a wider
variety of circumstances than say a man
on the street uh i mean
basically just search you
i mean like we have before them and
right but they can detain you and they
can frisk you
um yeah there's the uh um
shoot i'm forgetting the case somebody
versus ohio that yes they can frisk you
for for weapons and that and that people
have said that that's been you know
abused and all that but you still have a
reasonable expectation of privacy as
walking down the street that is a
relatively uh relatively broad broader
than a student's in a school is that
terry versus terry versus ohio that's it
i'm sorry i don't know about school but
uh i think
kids have a right to keeping bear arms
same as adults i just think the parents
have to be responsible for them and i'm
not saying it's the way it should be i'm
saying if if if if you look back at how
history was kids were handed weapons
you know kids would
they go out there's a boar you know in
the field you gotta you gotta stop it
it's destroying so they'd give the kid a
weapon and they would call up very young
people to fight and defend their
property from threats both foreign and
domestic
if these things are to be changed then
you need to have a convention of states
and change them
but i don't know maybe maybe i'm wrong
maybe there's precedent saying children
do not qualify as the people because
they fall into the jurisdiction of their
parents or something like that until
they enter the age of majority
all right but uh as for teachers yeah
good they should teachers janitors
principal they should all all of them
the teacher could have an ar-15 on their
back
i think they should i think they should
have a holstered weapon i mean the thing
is if the kids can't shouldn't be able
to go grab it but if it's locked in a in
a safe maybe
um then you're going to see a lot less
attacks it's not going to grab it if
it's holstered properly or whatever well
i mean i guess if you have a rifle
what was
was the teacher in this situation
allowed to have a weapon or not in texas
yeah i don't know i don't know anything
about it i mean it's texas they have
constitutional carry
even for teachers and schools i don't
know
constitutional carry does that
are there you know gun-free zones still
when they have when they've passed that
that's interesting
uh there there are indexes there are
certain uh
establishments that make more than 51 of
their uh 50 plus 1 percent of their
revenue from alcohol still you can't
carry in and there's a few others really
interesting robert
muir
says if we watch and do nothing they
will win
yes
boof says aaron and ian what's the
biggest cyber vulnerability people face
in 2022 that the average person isn't
aware of
well i mean i would just
20 20 things can get worse like we never
thought the political censorship would
happen
five years ago and it wound up happening
um it might not happen in 2022 but the
things we should watch out for are
things like they want
to make it so that it's impossible to
connect to the internet anonymously like
we should make sure that that's all it's
always allowed to connect to the
internet anonymously things like that
what are you thinking i i think it's
it's building on what i was just saying
about corporations versus government the
biggest vulnerability from my
perspective is a situation where the
government can ask a corporation to
enforce a dictate that it would not
otherwise be able to do you know what
i'm worried about is the executive uh
branch of this country being able to say
we would like so-and-so d-platformed we
would like so-and-so removed from public
discourse and
silicon valley a company they're obli
having the ability to do so and obliging
them you know doing so just knowing that
they'll get a favor from the government
in return or whatever you know because
the government could not do that on
their own
all right
deng lin wang says ian look into the eye
of sahara atlantis theory critics who
say it's false also say atlantis was
never real to begin with right up your
alley yeah it's the rakat structure it's
in mauritania africa everyone should
look this up on like google map or some
sort of map satellite map imagery if you
look up the rakat structure it is the
the ringed city of atlantis i mean
there's uh with
almost undeniable proof it's about the
same size i think that plato said it was
and it's got like water flow areas where
it looks like they dug out like a canal
to the water i mean it looks human the
humans were involved you can see ancient
rivers and stuff all around there that
are all dried out now all right sam
whitehurst says anytime i have a
philosophical dilemma i end up imagining
tim and ian having one of their classic
arguments representing the two sides of
my brain love you guys and all your work
ian if you're ever in florida let's
start a circle man oh i like it a drum
circle drop a circle you should imagine
it's not like an angel or a devil it's
me and ian yeah for sure you're wearing
all black we should we should do a bit
where it's like star trek where sheamus
is trying to make a hard decision yes
and you're giving him like a strong
emotional argument i'm giving a strong
logical argument yes that'd be funny
all right
dennibus x says as a longtime member as
a long-time member is of patriots.win
the successor to the donald we referred
to editing comments as spez since that
incident as a tribute to the head of
reddit that was his username
but let me just stress that point for
those that don't know
the ceo of reddit was so angry that he
was being made fun of he went into the
database and changed what users had said
about him nice
yo that's crazy it's so dangerous he
should have been he should like the
board should have removed him he should
have been fired i mean
that's what i guess he is the board
right like
yeah that's part of the problem like i
wonder if these companies these these
tech companies should even have a a
board or a leader like i know you guys
with right now are starting up um
like uh it's a it's a c corp yeah the
futo so
you're in charge yeah
but like at what point do you it was not
a social media network first of all
well it was kind of what i was talking
about with trust you know i would i
would hope that over time futo if we're
successful you know we'll have enough
you know of a track record that
individuals can decide that the things
that we kind of give a stamp of approval
have been vetted and are doing the right
thing in terms of like the situation
with reddit i mean absolutely all these
companies need to totally open up their
moderation process like
um league of legends did a very
interesting thing when they launched
where their moderation for their chat
and league of legends had a had a like
an open process for deciding who would
get like how their chat privileges
removed
um
there's no reason why every tech company
can't open up their moderation process
so we see exactly how these decisions
are made and you know
this the reddit guy would have been you
know we would have seen that what he did
all right
memo type says if only we'd all listened
if only we'd have all listened to
richard stallman from the beginning we
wouldn't be here you know problem with
stallman and this is one of the most
interesting i think of him as yoda the
yoda of the tech he's of if the force is
real he's yoda but he's like a troll
like he likes trolling people and he
called it free software even though it
makes it sound like it doesn't cost
anything it it just means that the
software code can be shared freely free
isn't speech not freezing beer yeah yeah
yeah
and he's like hahaha you know he he
likes that it's confusing that's the
problem with that guy i think i love i
mean i i have much love for the man but
that's that's my criticism of why people
aren't listening to him yeah he also
never really thought about how to like
incentivize programmers like like you
should be able to write software and ask
people to pay pay you for it like maybe
it can still be open source but you
could say like hey give me 10 bucks give
me a box of cookies or whatever if
you're using this software and if you
don't like you should delete it yeah
all right let's read some more
michael guinness says i was looking at
who was running in my district in new
york and i didn't see any republicans
running i was thinking of registering
republican and applying to run just for
the lulls you say just for the lulls but
this is how you win like
there how many stories it's like the guy
didn't really think it was going to win
i was gonna be funny and then all of a
sudden you find out you win
if there's if there's no republican
running your district and the gop is at
record turnout people are gonna be like
don't know don't care not democrat
rubber stamp you'll end up winning
so you know hey go for it
christopher knowles says children fail
to self-regulate regularly i think
parental limitations of children is for
the sake of their own future
self-regulation is parental limitation
censorship
i think one of the challenges is
at what point does the government act as
the parent because the parents you know
the government doesn't like what the
parents are doing
like truancy laws or curfew laws and
things like that
yeah if you if you give a little they're
gonna take a lot i think for sure
parents are censoring their children
they're deciding what they can and can't
eat what they can and can't watch where
they can and can't go um that's your job
that's your job as a parent that's one
of your main jobs in chicago if you're
under 18 you i think under 17 actually
you can't go outside after a certain
amount of after a certain time 600 pm
well that's new i mean it's always been
i think 10 30 or something like that
i just remember at uh like 11 15 just
after when i was 16 i believe i was 26
days from turning 17 but i got my curfew
violation in high school where in
chicago in chicago right so the cops
pull up and they're like get in the car
and they take you home and then your
parents have to sign off on it that is
insane to me
that there are hours where you are not
allowed to be outside because you're
under 17 or 18 or whatever it's 17 i
think right in chicago at the time it
was 17 when i was 16 i don't know what
it's currently you know right now but
think about back in the day when it's
like you were working on a farm you'd go
outside when you had to go outside it
didn't matter how late it was
you know you were
you had to be responsible now it's like
the government is just
it's a nanny state you know
yeah darkness is a little freaky or can
be things can hide
all right bootless uh bootless regent
says i don't know why i'm doing this but
it's my birthday today and i would like
to get a shout out for tomorrow when i
am listening to this love your work
shout out bootless regent happy birthday
birthday happy birthday bro birthday
happy birthday girl
the man the legend says bill gates made
his first billion selling dos
yeah i think he bought it for uh 50
grand
he he did a deal so my understanding is
he did a deal with ibm saying i can get
an operating system for your your home
computers and they were like okay and
then negotiated a deal like a dollar per
machine or some some something like that
and then probably more actually and then
he didn't actually have an operating
system he just you know said he did and
then he went found one and then brought
it to them and got the licensing deal on
it good businessman there you go they
did he-man too you guys ever see that
documentary about he-man the making of
he-man
no it's epic it makes sense yeah yeah we
talked about the original cartoon
original cartoon they went in there like
we have a character and a comic and a
cartoon and they're like we want it so
then they're like we got to build it i
always thought it was like repurposed
conan the barbarian toys that like they
couldn't get the license or something so
they made their own ip
to sell the same toys that were going to
be conan or something like that that's
one way to do it huh if for clockwork
there's also like an epic saga behind
the dolph lundgren movie that like it
was just like uh you know from the
beginning a total total uh mess
not sure
all right rylo 704 says please create
uniform linux software suites apps that
people actually want that isn't a
repackaged 20 year old program package
them as flat packs i will pay you
handsomely for your work
okay well there you go great we we want
to do that we want to encourage people
to do that exactly what he just said
all right
brian buck says would you be interested
in hearing opinions about dec and its
founder and ceo for years that did not
fit the mold of the controlling
narcissist type a tech ceo that
maintained a modest life lifestyle and
salary and had one hell of a product
interesting there's also that president
from uruguay remember that guy
yeah he was a farmer i was named jose
mojica or something
maybe and he like had a crappy little
car and he was like super chill and he's
like i don't care whatever i think he
was people really liked him
yeah was he a farmer probably smoked a
lot of pot yeah
yeah louis like knots the the new
president louie
steve bearden says tim shadow please i
am a disabled vet with a special needs
family trying to move to our homestead
property in alaska from washington state
we need help with our moving costs
thanks so much give send go mystical
wolf acres good luck man alaska
we should we need we need to occupy
alaska
we need to go there and start
building
i don't know what you'd eat
why is there no bridge to russia what
are they is that the most xenophobic
thing ever like come on
i don't think there's really a lot of
commerce up there
bearing straight bridge
how far is the bearing straight like 50
miles uh
if i recall correctly it's like
100 miles to an uninhabited island and
then another hundred miles across the
ground that's a very long time it's
inhabit the island yeah i mean it's
possible but i don't think there's
enough commerce for it to make i i think
the island isn't is it is inhabited oh
okay maybe by like a very small amount
of people very small yeah yeah so then
there's the field of dreams if you build
it bro have you have you guys ever
looked at the aleutians part of alaska
no they they go far
far across uh the pacific oh cool yeah
so it's it's cool i don't know i guess
they have on alaska i think it's called
one of the one of the cities they do
that's where that show about crabbing or
whatever it was what was that what was
that show dangerous catch deadliest
catch deadliest catches
like i'm gonna risk my lives to sell
crab
good stuff though man
out here yo crab soup
crabs everywhere it's so amazing it's
crazy cream of crab man it's so good we
went to the restaurant i got something
it's the best i got a name on that
uruguayan president jose mourinho
yeah
yeah he was a farmer it was awesome
all right spiro
floropolis says i can code your cued
word system i've submitted my resume two
times before we haven't heard anything
20 years experience well this project is
kind of like a community project so just
code it and put it up and then we'll
shout it out
right
someone said call it sources say
that's actually a really fun idea for a
website right you know
if he really wants to get paid he can
apply to be a futo fellow and we'll
consider it how do people apply so go to
fudo.org grants you'll see two things up
there we've got the futo fellows program
is listed right there got the details
there's also the photo legendary grants
which is for people have already done
great work we've made grants we're
talking about larry sanger's knowledge
standards foundation uh there's more to
come so on that so you'll fund the
sources say project if he applies for a
grant we will consider it
i might just do it because it's funny
just like oh actually right here yeah
duder 76 says call the site sources say
and that's the beginning to every post
oh that's brilliant actually
sources say
and then uh
what do we do we'll create
every we'll create like 10 posts and
we'll name them and then let the
community go in you ever see the thing
where they draw where they'll get like a
million pixels and then every user can
just draw on it all in real time oh
that sounds cool yeah that's a really
really cool project that they've done
periodically
and you can watch like someone will draw
the american flag
there'll be like 50 people all trying to
draw the american flag and then someone
will try to turn into the canadian flag
or whatever and they'll be competing and
then once again wins
yeah yeah yeah yeah i forgot what it's
called it's awesome yeah so you you guys
it's uh
f-u-t-o right futo futo.org
then you can check out the grants tab or
slash grants and it's written there
apply by june 15th we're getting towards
there
all right so so nine tailed fox says
kaffifi
not kov fifi
all right that's that's wrong but i
appreciate it
j.s feller says a better wikipedia would
allow users to fork pages and let
everyone see all the forks just like
github the most popular forks will win
out in the end interesting yes yes
what's the what's that
i think we need to look at wikipedia as
just a source of
diffs they're called diffs which is the
difference from one page to the next
if we just look at it as a source of
diffs you could actually just fork it
very easily by saying this editor wins
and this editor loses even though the
wikipedia foundation says the opposite
um we need to it's pretty complicated
software to build that but
it's kind of you know something we're
thinking about a lot and obviously larry
sanger's looking at this too
captain tanker joe says tim i need you
to do something for me stop calling
diesel gas when referring to what trucks
consume it's either called diesel or
fuel you'll get persecuted out here if
you say that
i don't know if if i have said that it
was it was it was an accident because i
typically refer to gas as gasoline and
diesel as diesel because i have diesel
vehicles and gas vehicles and electric
vehicle singular singular but uh so when
i say gas i'm referring to gasoline when
i'm saying diesel i'm referring to
diesel
anyway funny to me they have solid
liquid and gas and then gas is a liquid
i don't get it man humans are so weird
gasoline yeah it's it's a shortened for
gasoline right why they call it why
don't they call it liquid alien you know
it's not it's not gaseous
it's just a word do it i guess
nice job rockefeller
what's that it evaporates pretty quickly
that's true we don't go like you like
water a vapor
like it's just the word they use
it's water vapor not evaporate evaporate
no this is vapor it's gasoline it's a
word it's not it's like when people say
woman is derivative of men and it's
sexist or whatever when quite literally
they have different origins
and females
yeah male and female have completely
different linguistic origins i'm pretty
sure that's so weird yeah in britain you
know it's petrol and britain they they
think it's really funny we call it gas
too yeah
joseph says not true tim i used to be a
liberal when i had my epiphany it hurt i
still remember my psyche being shattered
when i realized what's going on
crazy
logan roldan says i am part of a youth
program that betters the community 501c4
that is in need of every dollar we can
get if we ask for a donation that is tax
deductible would you give us a grant
501c4 is not deductible not deductible
i'm pretty sure right yeah so that's a
political organization i believe which
makes it
is is i don't know if c is does c4 mean
over i don't think it means over oh yeah
it engages in politics yeah i think
that's the difference between a c3 and a
c4 it doesn't mean that it is a
political organization but that because
they will advocate for policy or a
politician it's a c4 that's why a lot of
non-profits that do political work while
the c3 and a c4 veritas is a good
example they have project veritas and
project veritas action
one is able to do you know operations on
politicians and one is not
confirmed it is not tax deductible 501
c4 is not tax deductible
plus we gotta we got to put funding into
our uh getting this uh
news rating agency and fact checking
thing up and running
steve
moleturno says create the ianpedia app
which services the wikipedia definition
accompanied by a tim factcheck label
wait for them to take you to court
there you go
all right we'll grab some more we got
sherman panzer if a civil war truly
comes to be i would have to wonder who
would be our real friends and foes upon
the world stage
china would be just
they'd be like yeah we're going to give
you money you know this faction and then
they're going to go to the other faction
we're going we're going to give you
money and just fund both
make them fight
all right
let's see where we're at
dark tannian says cali prime aries are
oh cali primaries it's split into two
words prime aries probably using voice
attack right california primaries are
june 7th i'm putting all my savings into
my own business and not above asking for
help
at givesendgo.com
cajun
are you running well good luck
refugee ca says why aren't police
departments located where schools are
kids could better see examples of what
happens when you make bad choices plus
better security that's an interesting
question
maybe it's because criminals are brought
there and they don't want your kids
they'd be releasing people
probably yeah
i mean probably just the parents would
complain
yeah
all right
uh
diver 867 says for the love of god
please someone tell me that there is no
wuhan institute of monkey box virology
i can't even tell you that
uh here's here's here's one from the the
real hydro oh must be it must be a first
time super chatter the gravity on mars
3.721
meters per second is it squared it's
hard to see the little tiny thing tim
how daffa is water going to fly away
please stop being a know-it-all my good
sir it's because water evaporates and
then water vapor leaves the atmosphere
okay i could be wrong about that on mars
but i'm pretty sure i was reading
something about that like low pressure
it would evaporate i mean lower
temperature water evaporates on earth
i mean i think it keeps its atmosphere
but for much less than earth does yeah i
mean i think they they think it had an
atmosphere in the past but it just went
away because the gravity wasn't strong
it's that scar that huge scar along mars
it looks like something rammed it and
ripped it open and all the magma came
out and covered the entire planet so you
got all this iron on the side dust now
okay four billion years ago or something
it was the great war
yeah wiped out human civilization and
then the survivors was a small small
band about six people crashed on earth
and had to rebuild and
that's it they wrote a book trying to
tell us everything we needed to do and
understand to survive
they called the book
yeah it's the valles marineris it's this
i don't know how long it is but that's a
4 000 kilometer trench that's my book
let's call it yeah no i was making a
joke about religion
all right let's see rando bunderson says
mars has an atmosphere albeit a very
thin one otherwise the helicopter drone
ingenuity on on it right now wouldn't
function ah yes well there you go i
stand corrected i think you know i was
just reading that uh it's difficult to
maintain or something they said that
it's a very thin atmosphere yeah that's
there it's it's like i was surprised
that that thing worked but it did wow
like like because it is like something
like one percent like compared to
earth's atmosphere
that's crazy
wow good for them all right my friends
if you have not already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a members show coming up at
about 11 p.m and we've got some major
updates coming and there's going to be
something really fun happening in a few
days i hope you're really excited for a
funny announcement we got cool stuff in
the works and it's all thanks to you as
members so we're gonna um
let's just say we plan on asserting
ourselves in uh in the culture and
dominating spaces typically held by the
establishment and we have plans coming
up the next few months to continually do
culture jamming as marketing so the
first run is not really all that crazy
but you'll see some interesting stuff
and we'll talk about it there's gonna be
some updates on the website some
infrastructure updates because we are
working towards being more resilient to
tech censorship so uh follow the show at
tim cast irl you can follow me at tim
cast aaron do you want to shout anything
out um
[Music]
yeah i mean you've heard a few times
already but yeah trying to make futo
successful we need everybody's help to
do that
we want to beat big tech
and that's futo
dot tell me futo.org
futo yes futo.org check out the grants
program food of fellows twenty thousand
dollars per team members up to five of
you if you're working on something a
cool technology that you you wanna get
started let us help you foodo.org slash
donation slash grants
grants you guys i wanted to shout out to
the official launch of the minds
festival of ideas mines is uh doing a
show in new york city on
june 25th i will be speaking also
confirmed as tim poole we have oh wow
that i got to see it turns out you're
good yeah he's good he's great dude yeah
he's really good cornell west we got
zubi we got majid noise the list goes on
you can go to and i have the the link
here for you it is festival.minds.com
get your tickets early because this
thing is going to sell out and we'll see
you there i think i think james james
o'keefe is going to be there too right i
believe so let's check it out o'keeffe
yeah he's on the list i think i'm
speaking with him oh good good that's
good we're going to drag on the media
together and then high five we're going
to be like the media sucks going to be
like yes boom yeah big lineup
seth dillon will be there just check it
out festival.mines.com
sweet awesome very cool i'm excited for
that thank you guys very much for tuning
in this evening i was correct i was
completely inundated with
tech talk i'll put it that way but i
appreciate it i hope you guys learned as
much as i did you guys can follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sourpatchlids
as well as sourpatchlids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
for that members segment thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you